So we have this hardware continuum from cell phones and PDAs to laptops,
to tablet's, to desktop computers, all the way to nodes in
a data center that is providing cloud computing services. Regardless of these
different manifestations and sizes, the organization
of the hardware inside the computer
system is pretty much the same. You've got a CPU. And the CPU is connected to
a conduit, which we call the bus. And
you've got memory that has the instructions and
data that is needed for the CPU to execute. And the CPU can use it's conduit,
namely the bus, to access the memory. And
you need storage for persistance of files and
other data that your produce during the computation. And, once again the CPU can
access stuff on the student's device through
a controller that is also connected to
this conduit. And you may have other peripheral devices, like a microphone and a
camera. All of these devices, of course,
are accessible for the CPU through this conduit,
which is the bus. And of course in this day, and age a device has to be
able to communicate with the outside world. You have a network, and once again
the network is interfaced through a controller to the CPU via
this conduit. So this conduit for communication Which is the BUS,
serves the purpose of connecting the CPU to the
memory as well as all the iode devices that
it may need to interact with in order to
do whatever the intent is of the user and
the application that they want to run on the
computer. And depending on the sophistication of the device
that we're talking about, and the speed of the
device that we're talking about. These controllers that I'm
showing you may have different capabilities. So for instance a
network controller may have the ability to
move the data directly from the memory into
the network, or from the network into the
memory and this As you may have learned
in a computer organization course, is called direct
memory access for the controller to move data
swiftly between memory and the IO device. And
similar DMA facility may exist in the controllers
of other high speed devices, this is the high
speed device. So that's the capability that you got
for some of these controllers. Some of these controllers
may be slow enough, for instance a keyboard or
a mouse, that the CPU can directly query new
data that is coming from the controller that is
associated with slow speed devices, and move it into
memory or use it in any fashion that it wants.